thanks for having me here i am happy to
be your last speaker i'll try to keep it
fun
so
you can go out with uh with a bit of a
bang
so today we're going to talk um about
um basically how to find failures so one
of the things i like to do in my spare
time is basically watch robots not do
what they're supposed to do and fail in
sort of fantastic ways um and often when
you look at
internet videos and things of robots
failing it seems like this is something
that happens all the time
um however we'll look at cases basically
where
assuming we have a relatively
well-defined or well-designed system
how can we actually find failures who
can do a deeper assessment and hopefully
correct them before we really release
them out into the world
so again today we'll basically be
talking about how we can
take these different robots in some
different contexts and how we can really
search the system and find failures um
in that and a lot of the work that we'll
be um that i'll be presenting today has
been done by two of my graduate students
uh peter dew and tian shinji as well as
some of the work in collaboration with
anthony and some folks here from from
swizzle
all right so let's kick it off and if
anyone has questions as i go along feel
free to raise your hand
we can we can keep it
informal all right so let's go ahead so
as a brief introduction um again a
little bit about myself um so i run the
human centered autonomy lab and what we
try and do is basically try to push
push the limits of robotics so we can
have more collaborative robots that work
right alongside people
be that in a very sort of collaborative
sense
or in a sense where we just
tried to save
get our videos to play first off
where these robots need to work on
people and hopefully for the most part
our videos will work but
once this happens we also again we like
to assess safety so when we really think
about deployment we can make sure that
these things are going to work as we
want be they working around people or in
very close context with them so this is
a bit
sort of an overview of what my lab tries
to do
and as you can tell even in these little
pictures here
there's a lot of different types of
applications that we look at in
particular we look at things in
agriculture so we look at field robots
we look at transportation where we have
autonomous vehicles
and as i just mentioned we have
collaborative robots in manufacturing
now these are very different areas and
each one has sort of their own nuances
and when we start thinking about safety
this actually becomes very important
because the tools that we use to assess
safety in say the manufacturing sense
might be very different from what we do
in the field robot sense
so one thing that we can try to start
building some intuition on is how do we
actually draw
some
linkage or really think about safety in
these very different contexts
so one thing we can note is that between
these different applications we have
this sort of notion of increasing
structure and i mean this in a very
loose sense
i don't have sort of a very formal thing
for this but it's more of really how we
describe this full this whole system so
for example in the manufacturing case we
usually have a very specific task that
we're trying to do we have a full
understanding of that whole process of
sort of what we want our system to do
and everything there we also have really
good control over that whole environment
so for example if i know that i need a
vision system that works for my
manufacturing robot
i can do whatever i need to to make that
vision system work as optimally as
possible i can control the light
conditions um i even have some control
over the workers and what they do um if
i'm having a hard time tracking them i
can add things to what they do so
there's a lot of sort of structure in
how we can design this the system
um on this other end here if we're
looking at like a field robot
even though if you're thinking about
something like a robot that's like
working on a farm
it seems like there's some structure but
in reality there's actually very little
and it's very hard to understand for
what's what's going on in this this
scene
so it becomes very hard to even do some
things like define what a failure is in
this case we kind of know what a
collision is but it can be very hard to
detect in these really tough tough
environments
so
in somewhere in the middle here is we
have these autonomous vehicles which
have a lot of structure in that we have
rules of the road we have this sort of
agreed upon way that we're all going to
drive how we're going to operate and how
things work
however you will always have sort of
these violations and what you expect in
your environment you'll have crazy
weather that comes in you'll have people
doing who knows what so you do have a
lot of sort of things that can come in
and add to the uncertainty and whatnot
there
so depending on these different sort of
applications you can kind of start
thinking about the different
the different modes of operation and
whatnot here and again we can start
thinking about the different tools that
we might need if we want to start
analyzing the safety of these systems
again hopefully prior to
to deployment um here
and as another sort of quick aside so as
we have this sort of increasing
structure this also really changes the
type of
the type of tasks and sort of the the
expectations of the system themselves so
what we can do is we can add sort of
another layer here and you can start
thinking about something like the
different sort of expectations of
autonomy so you can think about like the
levels of automation
or sort of modes of interaction that you
might have in these sort of different
settings so the most obvious one for
this is thinking about like the levels
of autonomy for a
um autonomous vehicle so in this case
you can have a fully autonomous vehicle
it is fully driving
you kind of know what to expect
and you can kind of design your system
around something here whereas if you
have lower levels of autonomy where you
have say you're sharing control with
that human um this sort of has sort of a
different different thing that you would
expect from from your overall system and
you can say this for for other the other
applications too
whereas again we have sort of a similar
very high level of autonomy um for these
robots and this is sort of what is in
practice today for manufacturing robots
and actually often what we're trying to
do is sort of bring it down so you can
have more collaborative robots so in
many ways you're trying to make the
robots less autonomous have them work
more with people and again this is
something that you sort of want to bring
bring down here
on the other side here we can have this
person monitoring the single robot or we
can have something where the human is
monitoring full fleets um but when you
have less structure you're basically
never going to have the same sort of
fully autonomous system like you would
have over here just because of the
nature of the problem so going back to
just this original point though
we want to sort of think about safety
and we're going to think about it in
this sort of notion of structure so what
can we say about the problem what can we
say about sort of what's going on here
and again how can that inspire how we're
going to solve the problem how we're
going to do things like find failures in
the system
so if we have really well specified
models you might be able to use more
rigorous analysis you can have formal
methods you can use more analysis based
approaches where you can say okay here's
the parameters that i have here's the
model that i'm going to use and here's
basically everything that i can prove or
say about my system
however as we move sort of down to this
lower structure
we kind of need to start thinking a
little bit more creatively about how
we're going to find these tools
so we're going to spend most of our time
today talking about these sort of two
different applications so first we're
going to think about simulation based
validation so this is a case where we
have our autonomous vehicle we have our
system and we actually have a decent
idea of how it behaves but again we sort
of have these
some special cases or some scenarios
where it kind of breaks down so we have
this sort of semi-structured
environment however we can run
simulations on it and that's sort of the
key thing here when we have some idea of
what we're going to do we have some
sense of the model we can kind of build
up our simulation there and we can start
looking at tools for how we actually
find failures in the system
and then at the end we'll talk about
this very unstructured case where we can
actually uh we can't really rely on
things like simulation to help us find
um failures and sort of understand
what's going on
so instead we can sort of look at
proxies for failure detection or these
more rigorous approaches um and just
look at like anomalous cases
so a little bit more of a pure
data-driven perspective here
okay so that's what we're going to talk
about um today so let's go ahead and
talk about this first case we'll talk
about simulation based validation and
again in the context
of autonomous vehicles
all right so if i were to give you an
autonomous vehicle uh to control and
let's say that uh i want you to design
the system so it's robust against all
kinds of noise or all kinds of
uncertainty let's say um
despite you know people acting a little
bit strange some noise in your sensors
things like that
so often if you were to take sort of a
more traditional approach you might cast
this as a robust decision making or
control problem and you tried to write
it something like this
where you have this system that you're
trying to control so it's guided by some
dynamics f so this can be the dynamics
that guide your your vehicle and you
want to find that controller so again
you want to basically find how you drive
this car
um and you'll have some disturbances and
this can basically model all of the
uncertainties so hopefully if you can
capture all of this uncertainty all the
disturbances in the world you can find
this controller and you can be safe safe
against them and that's sort of the
intuition behind this robust control or
this but robust decision making approach
um and this is something that really
came about when we started thinking
about adding things like sensor noise
maybe you have some uncertainty in where
you are or something
in your sensors maybe you have some
uncertainty in say like the road
friction um or some detection
uncertainty um and this is sort of
really meant for these sorts of these
sorts of systems so again this is
something that's sort of well studied in
control so hopefully you don't violate
any constraints you can basically
stabilize and control the system the way
the way you want it to
um so this is our one class of systems
that it was like really well or did a
really good job handling
um however this has become sort of more
popular a little bit more recently as
people started thinking about things
like model mismatch um so this is still
something that people were interested in
when they first came about from the
control perspective um where maybe you
have some unmodeled dynamics
in your system
but this also became more popular when
people started thinking about okay we're
training lots of things in the real
world or in simulation we want them to
work in the real world there's going to
be some gap between the two of them you
can actually capture some of this
through this sort of robust robust
decision-making framework so this came
about in the form of things like robust
rl adversarial rl and things like that
where you kind of tried to handle all of
this
um and again one of the big issues like
i mentioned you have something running
in simulation you have some mismatch
between things you tend to sort of get
this cascading error so here's sort of
an example of things getting worse and
worse over time where you have an
unstable method
so again this sort of robust or
adversarial approach can help you come
up with systems that are more more
robust in this case
okay
so this is sort of what this was
handling but really when we're thinking
about autonomous vehicles
deployed in the real world again a lot
of the issues that we really think about
don't really come from things like
having like not a good model of your
vehicle or
having some uncertainty in your noise
they often come from something a little
bit different
so they often come from things like
failures and interaction
so
these sorts of methods don't really
capture these sort of longer term sorts
of scenarios these longer term
interactions that again are sort of the
things that lead to these sort of more
interesting um failures here
so
to sort of really push past this point
where okay we have a system that we can
get to work fairly well on the road
we've sort of resolved some of these
robustness issues now how do we
sort of really actually think about the
real issues that happen the things that
they encounter on the road and how can
we start using that sort of to inform
how we design the vehicle itself
so to do this as i sort of pointed out
earlier we're going to turn to this
simulation-based validation
and part of why we turn to the
simulation based validation
is because uh as i mentioned uh it's
actually kind of hard to find failures
once you've resolved a lot of these
these issues these sort of failures are
sort of too and far between
so uh these numbers are a little bit out
of date but they're still
relatively relatively insightful
um so when you think about autonomous
vehicles um on the road
um you have this sort of interesting
issue where you have very high risk
events so you have things like
collisions they're actually very rare or
sort of low probability events so if you
look at the collision rates of people
driving so how frequently people get
into collisions so we get about just
over 10 per 100 million kilometers
driven so this is a pretty rare event on
how rate just humans regular human
drivers get into these sorts of
collisions
um and their fatality rate is
significantly lower um here
so if we want to try to show that our
autonomous vehicle is sort of being
robust or doing better than human
driving we have to do sort of orders of
magnitude more testing
and hopefully on road to actually show
that we're better than that human driver
um which isn't really uh something that
is feasible for most people who are
designing autonomous vehicles
waymo can try they can deploy lots of
things they can get those those vehicles
out but again it's very hard to really
show on the real world that you're
actually better than than a human driver
so that's one thing so because this sort
of real world testing is not very
feasible
often what people do is again as i've
mentioned we turn to simulation so what
we're going to try to do is say okay we
can't deploy fleets and fleets of
vehicles and get hundreds of millions of
kilometers driving but we can try and do
this in simulation so we can come up
with some sort of relatively realistic
simulation and see what we can do from
there so let's say i wanted to test test
my vehicle i have some pretty nice
simulator let's say i'm using something
like carla
and i designed the scenario and i tested
a bunch of times so if i do that let's
say i have this pedestrian and this car
and we have them sort of
coming into this interaction we want to
make sure that this system is overall
safe
so i can basically run this simulation i
can design
everything i want
and sort of come up with some
some idea of how safe this this system
is and again this is assuming that i can
sort of have this simulation and i can
query it and sort of test it test it
from there
the problem is
that there's this common saying
that simulations are doomed to succeed
so the problem is i'm the one who's both
designing the system
and i'm the one who's designing this the
simulator eventually i'll be able to get
it to work the way i want it to so it's
very easy to sort of trick yourself into
thinking that this system is going to
work exactly the way i want it to um a
lot
and there's a number of different
reasons for this one
because we are the ones sort of
designing these models and designing
these simulations again we're just going
to kind of encode it with with our own
biases and again things are often much
nicer in simulation than actually in in
the real world
um the other thing is just very hard to
actually come up with a good way to
search the space if you're just doing
sort of random sampling or just running
your simulation you're just going to
sort of get an idea of average behavior
which again is something that you've
sort of encoded
so as a little example
let's say i wanted to sort of come up
with a bunch of test cases
so one thing you can do is come up with
a bunch of uh
sort of test cases or test what they
call test matrix so if we have something
like two vehicles i could define a few
variables that i want to sort of sweep
over say
like the speed between these different
cards the different distances and
whatnot i could sort of come up with my
test case
i'm here so even this where i only have
three variables that i'm trying to sort
of sweep over and i have some
discretization that i'm sweeping over
here
i'm going to have a ton of simulations
here so this is even in this like little
example
it's over a hundred thousand scenarios
so even though
uh i'm only doing a relatively small
test this is still quickly becoming
infeasible so even though i'm turning
the simulation which is much more
efficient than real world testing it's
still getting to the point where i'm
basically going to be basically
uh swimming through data that i don't
know what to do with it and maybe it's
not that useful
okay
and as a sort of another example maybe
we can make it a little bit more
complicated and go back to that scenario
that we were showing before where we
have a vehicle that's approaching this
pedestrian
um i could do something like come up
with a model of how i think this human
is going to behave and some do something
like sweep over different velocities
kind of like in this test case approach
so i can propagate this forward and sort
of see how this car interacts with this
different pedestrian here
um but
this isn't really capturing uh realistic
human behavior so one thing we can do is
we can start augmenting things like this
model of how we think this human is
going to behave and start sort of
building up from there so we can have
more interesting test cases here so say
we add some lateral movement we can
start sampling sampling this way um here
so we can start sort of getting more
more weird behavior but again one thing
that's very hard and again because we
are designing these simulations it's
unclear if this is really capturing real
behavior so maybe we'll miss something
like a weird motion like this
and it's kind of unclear maybe this is
something that is very useful to test
maybe it's something that's not okay so
that's one of the things that's sort of
very challenging about this is it's just
hard to know what is a meaningful test
and how we can sort of efficiently get
to to points like this
the other thing that's very hard here is
we're just looking at this sort of two
two case as with this example we're only
looking at things like three variables
and as we get to more and more realistic
um situations like say we add other
vehicles that then have their own
decisions um things get really really
complicated so we have this
combinatorial explosion of all these
different scenarios we need to test and
whatnot so really what we want from this
though is a tool that can help us search
through this simulation and help us more
effectively basically find things like
the most likely failure so for example
maybe we just sort of get into a
collision with this pedestrian and we
want to make sure that we're robust or
sort of can be safe against these sorts
of actions
so that's why we're going to turn to
this tool called adaptive stress testing
which again will hopefully help us more
efficiently search through the
simulation and help us sort of get to
that point where we can very quickly and
very easily sort of find relevant and
interesting failures in our system which
again should give us more insight to how
the system sort of actually behaves
so um in adaptive um stress testing um
which came out of sizzled by ritually
basically assume that we have this
simulator so as before we have our
autonomous vehicle scenario we kind of
set some things up we can basically
query this this simulator here
from this we have some states or
observations this is going to go into a
reward function and an rl solver so what
we're going to do in this is we're going
to
uh basically use rl and rl solvers to
help us basically efficiently search
through this this space so we're going
to take advantage of these tools and
these solvers and machine learning and
again basically help us quickly search
search of space to find something that
will sort of maximize this reward and
guide us towards this adversarial
policies that basically give us these
failure cases
so we're just going to use this as an
efficient search engine here
and um here basically what this rl
solver is going to do it's going to
produce a policy
a policy that will basically augment
environment actions so this is going to
be basically control different things in
our environment for example could be
this pedestrian it could be noise in our
sensors and again help us drive drive
the system towards towards failure
so a lot of this basically comes down to
how we actually use this reward function
here and how we tune that to basically
guide us and guide our simulation or
failure identification problem towards
these most likely failures so a lot of
this comes down to how we actually
define this function
and intuitively basically what we want
to do is we want to
try to guide our system towards failure
so we give this system a penalty
basically for not finding some failure
and we give it some penalty for taking
unlikely actions so we don't want
totally crazy things um for the
pedestrian to do or force the
environment uh to do more generally we
basically want to find things that are
more obvious or more likely to to happen
here so a lot of it basically comes down
to how we're going to guide and how
we're going to search
and search our system
okay so let's go back to this sort of
more simple example and start sort of
breaking this down
a little bit
so let's um for this example we have
this simulator again so we have our
system under test so this is our vehicle
that we want to try and find the
failures in
again assuming that it's a relatively
robust
robust system here
and we have some environment actions
that we can start sort of probing and
querying here
um so in this case we're going to start
looking at the participant dynamics in
this case this is basically the model or
the actions that this
pedestrian can take so we want to start
thinking what are the different actions
that this
person can take and how can it affect my
vehicle or can i be robust against
basically these these actions and we'll
also add some noise to the measurements
here so we can start basically
giving some uncertainty to where we
actually think
the the system is and this will give us
an idea of how robust or how how much we
can handle in terms of our perception
uncertainty which directly impacts our
decision making here
okay so from this simulator we have um
everything comes to a reward function
which is um as defined before we want to
look at the sort of likelihood um the
likelihood of our actions um and again
trying to drive it towards these likely
likely failures
and we have this solver
in theory you can use pretty much any rl
solver you just need to search this
space and try to maximize that reward
one thing that we do a lot in my lab is
we use monte carlo tree search because
one of the nice things you can get is
you can kind of get things like risk
curves out of it gives you a little bit
more insight and a little bit more
interpretability but in general you can
use any any solver
okay so now we have this tool we have
adapted stress testing we have this
whole system and we actually want to run
it okay so let's um think a little bit
about what what we actually get out of
this this system
so again if we were to just take our
typical simulation we were to query it a
lot we'd probably get things that look
like this we have this sort of
simulation these systems that are
basically just going to give us
something give us something close to
average average behavior
now if i were to just go for a pure
adversarial adversarial approach where i
just want to find a worst case example
i'd probably get something that looks
like this
that i sort of hinted at before
where we just have this pedestrian it's
just running straight into the car
so we kind of can uncover this
suicidal pedestrian case which yes
ideally we would be able to avoid such
collisions but really when we think
about it it's not really this vehicle's
fault
here
so one of the challenges with a lot of
these methods is you want to kind of
balance things like what is the actual
behavioral model that is guiding this
how adversarial or and how likely your
issue actually is so what we really want
to do is try to find these relevant
failures for example this the pedestrian
isn't acting particularly abnormal yes
they are sort of edging towards the
uh the sidewalk here but you can see we
have a lot of detection noise and
detection uncertainty and this kind of
changes things so this kind of failure
is much more relevant and much more
interesting in many ways to actually
designing the vehicle than something
like this
these sort of unavoidable cases
so okay we have this tool we can find
failures maybe we'll end up with
something like this
ideally we'll find something that's
again more insightful like this so the
question is how do we actually get from
here say
to to here
so pulling back on this
slide one of the big things here is
everything is guided basically by this
reward function here and this again it
guides our search process and will
ultimately produce different types of
failure modes here so
one thing that you can do is you can
start thinking about how to shape or how
to tune this reward function to again
hopefully help you find things that are
a little bit more relevant or
interesting so we can start thinking
about how we can take things like domain
expertise and incorporate this into the
learning process
since even we as
i guess we're all ai safety experts in
this room now or you will after this
lecture and you'll have finished the
class
uh we want to figure out how you can
take all that knowledge and again
hopefully start using using this here
so um there's a few different things
that you can do and there's a few
different things that we've we've
explored um here
so
for example um one thing that you can do
is you can take things like
the responsibility sensitive safety
metrics so rss this is a basically
heuristics that came out of intel
mobileye
that basically set sort of
intuitive rules for how a vehicle should
behave if you follow these rules you'll
never be at fault
so if we can start encoding this into
this reward function we can start
finding things like more relevant
failures for example
something like this where
there's just sort of some weird
misunderstanding and eventually we get
into an accident so this is sort of a
weird dance so let's look at a top-down
view so we can maybe get a little bit
more insight and this will also show a
few more agents involved so in this case
uh we have this sort of top-down view we
can see there's sort of this dance
between pedestrians and in the vehicle
here and it ultimately results in a
collision so this is something where we
violated sort of our own sort of code of
ethics through this rss framework and
we've resulted in a failure here
so again by adding this domain insight
into that reward function we can find
things that are a little bit more more
interesting
another thing that we can do
is we can start adding things that can
actually help the search itself so one
of the problems with using an rl
framework is typically reinforcement
learning is trying to find one single
policy that is optimal you want to
control your robot to say walk across
the room and you want to find that best
that best policy the problem is is when
you're finding examples of failures we
don't really just want to find one
failure but we want to find many
different failures so one thing you can
also do is start basically adding um
different things to this reward function
to find a diverse set of policies so
then you can find lots of different
failures so for example in this similar
scenario where we have two pedestrians
which are the easiest things to make
fail because pedestrians can do anything
we can actually find scenarios where
we actually get into
oops
into situations where
where it's a collision between these two
vehicles here you can see here there's
some sort of weird behaviors we actually
get rear-ended in this case
so by basically taking some sort of
intuitive insights and again really
thinking about how to design the reward
function we can start sort of pushing
that domain insight into the failure
search and again find more diverse and
more relevant failures here
so this is sort of one one thing we can
do
um and the what i've talked about thus
far in sort of thinking about reward
augmentation um is very much um still we
are engineers we sort of have an idea of
what we want we either have our list of
rules from rss or we have some sort of
clear idea of what we want from our
policy but this doesn't really tell us
um how we can sort of hand this to any
person and maybe give something that's a
little bit more intuitive and sort of
the end result here
so one of the things we can do is start
thinking about how we can do things like
identify critical states and really
think about how we can do this in a more
general way to sort of generally get
human insights to help guide guide the
search process
so one thing we can do is we can take as
i mentioned this insight from critical
states
so because it's sort of infeasible to
really test
over all
all different scenarios and what not
we want to try and see if we can sort of
cool this down into these sort of more
key states
which we'll call these critical states
which hopefully will also capture these
critical scenarios
and hopefully since we're thinking about
safety these are things that are sort of
near collisions or sort of um tend to be
accident prone or might be a little bit
more risky
so there's a lot of work in
sort of the human side of robotics i
really try to understand sort of how
people interpret critical states
and what people think are important
and this has been shown to really help
do things like build mental models so if
you can find these critical states you
can show this to people and they can
have a better understanding of how your
system performs which again is sort of
what we're trying to do anyways
but through failure analysis so what we
can try and do is try to basically
capture things like critical states
which might be things like um
approaching a red light seeing how we do
this how we operate around pedestrians
um and kind of look at these sort of
again key scenarios and see if that can
sort of help guide again all for our
failure um situations
so to um to do this we basically need
ways to again find these critical states
and again hopefully in a way that's
intuitive and then we can easily feed
sort of into this validation or this
search search process here so there's a
number of different ways you can do this
sort of depending on what you have on
hand
so one thing you can do is you can hand
craft scenarios so that's sort of what
you can do in situations like this you
can basically take again your pool of
experts and say okay these are the
important situations we can either set
those up in simulation or try to encode
them somehow you can do this sort of by
by hand
but again this doesn't scale very well
we'll run into those sort of issues as i
talked about earlier
another thing that you can do is
depending on the type of policy that
your
vehicle is running or sort of the the
inner workings of how it's going
sometimes you can sort of peek inside
and see if there's some insight you can
get from the policy itself for example
if you have some way to track
uncertainty you can take those states or
those scenarios where your vehicle is
uncertain and you can specifically look
at those
this is something that is not easy to do
in general but if you happen to have
a vehicle or a policy that sort of
follows something um nice like this then
you can um think about trying to encode
that in
um similar to these handcrafted
scenarios if you have some sort of very
specific heuristics or domain insights
you can start sort of putting that that
indirectly similar to what we did in the
previous
previous slide and videos
or what you can do is you can try to
more directly so do something like human
in the loop learning where you can try
and actually just sort of collect human
data
collect feedback from our experts and
see if we can use that to guide the
search itself
so this is one of the things we explored
so by
having this tool that can help generate
scenarios
and generate things that may or may not
be interesting
one thing that we can do is we can
basically try to
get a bunch of people to start labeling
different scenarios as if they are
critical or risky or not so um basically
we look at this onlooker's perspective
so we show the person some videos so if
i were to show you an example of a car
driving you could tell me if you think
it's risky or not and we can try and
learn this human model and incorporate
that into our search process so we
basically get a proxy for how risky you
as people think that a system is
so we can both do this with something in
simulation and we can also do things
like label different
data sets um that basically can tell us
how critical
a scenario is and again like i said
incorporate this into the search process
so we can basically
continually collect more examples that
may or may not be risky and hopefully
learn learn a good model
in general if you have a very good
expert this is great if you don't have a
good expert this is noisy so it is a
little bit sensitive here but what you
can do is you can start sort of
collecting those sorts of insights and
again pushing your system towards these
failures that tend to be a little bit
more intuitively risky so in this
example we'll look at this highway
highway scenario so this is our test
environment so we have our green car
and it is navigating this
uh this environment here is basically
just trying to go through the freeway
without getting any collisions
so if you were to apply our
heuristic methods
as before so just sort of the naive
ast methods
we'll find failures that you might
expect so we can find this sort of
getting very close or near collisions
during a lane change um or just one lane
following but basically all these
failures basically look the same
and again they kind of are
intuitive because collisions we all know
what that is um but they're not very
diverse um and they might not sort of
capture the full range of what we think
is dangerous
um but if we start thinking about this
sort of human in the loop approach we
still get these similar
scenarios where we have this like loss
of forward separation during the lane
change or just in general but we also
get other types of risky behavior that
aren't actually traditionally failures
in the way we might
think for example we have this traffic
cut off this is a risky behavior it's
probably something we don't want our
vehicle to do too much
but again this is captured basically by
this human insight here
similarly um here we just have this
really close lane change um as well
which is something that's not sort of
traditionally captured um in this this
sense um here
okay
so
what we've been talking about is
basically this method for ast so this is
again it's this tool that helps us find
these failures in relatively complex um
complex systems here and again it allows
you as designers more anyone else to
sort of peek in to what's going on and
again sort of get some idea
for your system it can be a very sort of
generic black box system you just need
to be able to simulate your system
forward and again have some idea of sort
of what's going on on the inside here
one of the problems as we sort of noted
you don't always get intuitive results
you tend to get something that might be
a little bit crazy or a little bit out
of the blue
but using these different heuristics and
these different approaches we can find
something that is much more relevant
and interesting to us as the people
trying to design these these autonomous
systems um here
and again this comes from insight from
these domain experts so we can kind of
get an idea of what what is risky here
so hopefully you can test test your
system out and then you will be
eventually brave enough so you can do
things like uh walk in front of a car
let's see if it'll start over here so
you can fully test it before deploying
it so again
you can trust your grad students too to
let you walk in front of a car here
and i guess since we're all friends here
i would love to say that this worked 100
of the time but it didn't
occasionally your students will still
come very close to trying to run you
over albeit at a slow speed but you know
it works most of the time
all right
okay so
this is basically um for now all i have
to say about the simulation based
validation and again this is a tool that
works very well in helping you find and
understand these sorts of failures when
you have this situation where you can
model what's going on to some extent you
can kind of have your system that you
can query and you can kind of explore it
in a relatively intuitive way
however as i mentioned earlier depending
on the sort of structure of your
environment and sort of what you
actually know about your system
sometimes this is just not feasible
and this is definitely the case
in field robotics
and in specifically agricultural robots
which is not as relevant of a robot
here at stanford but in illinois we are
surrounded by cornfields so it is much
more prevalent of a problem there
so okay so now we're going to talk about
um anomalous failures in a slightly
different context um here
so to just give a little bit of a
motivation so
these field robots that we'll be working
with are basically part of this idea of
trying to make um agricultural fields
more autonomous
so a little fun fact um the agricultural
industry is actually one of the most
dangerous in the u.s
there are lots of issues that happen a
lot of it comes from just the dangers of
working with uh
really big systems like silos
and in particular really large robotic
tractors
which
maybe some are robots some are not but
becoming more autonomous
so we work with these relatively small
robots here that are meant to go out
into the field
and ideally you want them to robustly go
up and gather data perhaps perform some
more uh precision agriculture things and
whatnot here
but again one of the big challenges is
getting them to work in these kind of
crazy field environments
and we really want to get them to the
point where they can start replacing
these much larger
larger equipment like tractors which
again are very dangerous
and one of the things that we've been
doing is trying to push basically how
autonomous these these systems can be
again kind of pushing this level of
of autonomy up and again sort of pushing
how
how capable they are
so one thing we can start doing first is
starting to think about how we can make
these systems more autonomous one way we
can do it is first by just sort of
codifying what we need these systems to
do this is something that um in
autonomous vehicles as i sort of hinted
at before we have this kind of idea of
what we want them to do at different
levels we have these levels of autonomy
first of what the expectations of the
of the vehicle are and sort of how we
want them to operate
um and for field robots you can actually
make sort of parallels um that are very
similar where you can start sort of
making some parallels with what the
robot should be able to do with respect
to the human so for example in say like
level one autonomous driving you have
partial automation but you basically
need to have your hands on the wheel um
similarly if you have something for a
field robot case you might be able to
monitor the robot but you can basically
sort of
be very close put your hands off
and hopefully we can get to this point
where you basically have this point
where you don't have the person that
needs to be there anymore you just have
these robots
autonomous autonomously operating
but again to sort of get to this point
we can really get them operating at
scale we need them to be robust to these
failures
and again we can't necessarily use those
same
tools that we've been talking about
because we don't have that same insight
to the structure of the environment so
we'll show a few videos of the issues
but let's first look at a clean case so
you get an idea of what these robots are
doing so we have these robots they go up
and down things like cornrows
um here and for the most part they're
actually pretty good um at doing this
and they're also small enough that
they're not uh not too dangerous um here
um i usually stop the video here because
here you can see we sort of have this
still one to one we don't quite trust
the robots enough to sort of be
operating on their own and that's
because occasionally as they're going
they will get into some trouble perhaps
there's too much mud on their wheels
there's something in the world and they
will eventually fail
so and again this is sort of acute
failure this is not catastrophic but if
you think about slightly larger
autonomous robots it actually gets very
dangerous very quickly
and especially with sort of the rolling
out of larger equipment
it's sort of an issue
now one of the big challenges with this
is the failures that you tend to find um
in these field environments are very
unique and again like i said they're
very hard to actually sort of codify
when we think about autonomous driving a
collision is where we have two agents
that have overlapped
it's very difficult to actually detect
things like collisions actually in the
field you can come up with things that
you might think will capture all types
of failures but they'll tend to fail
in some cases like for example if you
think it is stopped um that means it's
gotten to a collision but sometimes its
wheels will keep spinning so you'll
think it's moving and it's not um you
also don't really have access to good
things like gps
so you can have a really hard time
telling if your robot's actually stopped
um or not
so again one of the things that we're
going to do is turn to some other
uh other tools so we can try to identify
failures and we're going to do this uh
following is actually a fairly similar
intuition to what we had before
where we have these sort of similar
issues where we have data and balance
where again we have these sort of high
risk but low probability events
so most of our data that we get
is actually normal driving data so we're
just going up and down the fields and
we're pretty good at it
but occasionally we will find these
sorts of failure systems or failure
cases and we'll only get a few examples
of that so we'll have lots of data about
this
and very little little here so this is a
very challenging problem in most uh most
types of systems where we kind of have
this sort of uh flipped or sort of
imbalanced data um here where we have
lots of this and we can learn a lot from
sort of this sort of data but again we
won't basically be able to capture much
about this because we have so few
examples relative to how much
uh good data that we have
but again when we're thinking about
things like failures this is sort of the
flip of what we what we want so this is
the one that is like sort of much more
important
and these we sort of have this down we
don't really care about this this as
much so we basically need to come up
with ways again we can start basically
looking for these sort of anomalous
events or these rare events and starts
sort of using that as a proxy for for
failures so we're going to be sort of
relaxing
this sort of true idea of a failure and
just start looking for these sort of
rare events
and maybe they're failures maybe they're
not chances are it's a it's a failure at
least in our our experience
so just so some examples that maybe
perhaps aren't
quite as as silly
so here's an example of just normal
driving through the field
so as you can see this is like
normal good
good situations and
i think this video also shows why it's
hard to come up with a good simulation
this is something that's very very hard
to recreate there's things like weeds in
the way you have very odd lighting very
odd visibility you're basically going
through things like these leaves all the
time so this is the normal normal
driving case
that for the most part is good and where
most of your data comes from
but we've sort of identified four
different different failures
that tend to happen pretty frequently so
the first
is a row collision so this is similar to
what
what we were showing before
where you kind of just run into the edge
here and again the thing to note
from a perspective a perception point of
view
these don't look that different right so
it's kind of hard to tell the difference
between these two two scenarios
um the two other common failures are
running into
untraversable obstacles so this is
obstacles
which yes it is just hard to see
sometimes
there's something in a way in this case
there's a plant stock that is in the way
that we cannot push through
and that causes our robot to fail so
that's one one thing so it could be
something like a stock a weed a grad
student all kinds of things here
and the other case is this traversable
obstacle here where say there's
something like in the way but if you
push past it or maybe sort of increase
the torque you actually could get over
it so it's a failure but it's uh
recoverable
so these are some different cases that
are pretty common
and again we have some data for these
but not a ton
we have lots of data for this so what we
want to do is again we want to formulate
this problem of failure identification
so we want to find the same thing as
before we want to find these issues
where our system fails but we're going
to cast this as an anomaly detection
problem okay so basically we want to
find these uncommon events and hopefully
we can categorize it as one of these
sort of failure cases um here
so the nice thing about this anomaly
detection approach
is it does inherently consider these
concerns where we have this data and
balance we have these sort of rare
situations here
and also because we are sort of already
dealing with fact that we have very
little data and we don't have just
unlimited resources with stimulation
we can do things like we're okay with a
small data set and because these systems
are actually tracked by a person for the
most part we can actually get labeled
data that's just obtained by human
intervention so when the robot fails we
can label that on online and this can
sort of help build up our data set and
again hopefully this sort of helps us
increase this autonomy by giving the
robot some awareness of when it's
encountered this failure so this is more
of an online approach than what we were
talking about before which is sort of a
pre-pre-deployment
case
okay so
the way we're going to do this um is
basically through um some learning
approaches since again we have this data
set um and we can go from there so one
classic way you could do this
is you could basically use a classifier
this can be something that is very
simple
like perhaps you want to gather some
information about the distributions you
can do some hypothesis testing
or you can do something that's a little
bit more advanced like throw some
machine learning at it and again you try
and do something like throw a classifier
at it either as normal or not normal or
as one of the different test cases that
we have
so that's sort of one one way you can do
it that's an approach that some some
people use
um one of the things that's often very
hard
is because our perception input is most
of the information that we have um it's
very high dimensional and it's actually
very tricky to sort of balance this with
some other other data so that's
something that is typically tricky um
with this sort of approach
another common approach these days for
looking at anomaly detection is actually
to look at methods for reconstruction so
um for example uh one common approach is
to basically use an encoder decoder type
approach so you have your data you have
your observations
you basically um pass this through your
encoder so you get a small latent space
representation and you try to
reconstruct that same scene so for
example i put in my uh
lidar point cloud i tried to basically
reconstruct it
and the assumption that people typically
make with this sort of vae type approach
is if you have a good reconstruction
error so if you are able to reproduce
this this sample it's probably something
that is very well represented in your
data set
so assuming you have a good model
assuming you can have some good
confident reconstruction
um you can basically do a really
solid idea of just identifying what is
normal and what what is not
i'm here
um so that's one thing that you can do
for this
if you have something that isn't well
represented in your data set
probably your model is not going to a
good job going to do a good job
reconstructing it and in that case it's
likely an anomaly so you can basically
use the thresholding technique on your
reconstruction here to try and try and
get this out
so one thing that we found is we can
also get some more insight because we
have this labeled data
we can basically also label the data to
get these different failures so we can
get a little bit more insight um to
what's going on and this basically gives
you a little bit more structured of of a
reconstruction
so again here we have something like our
light out point cloud that's coming into
this say feature generation
and we basically want to do something
like perhaps reconstruct this or again
ideally identify what kind of failure
that we have um here
so at runtime what we're just going to
do is we're just going to run this path
where we have our data or our data from
our robot we're passing this in we're
trying to identify sort of what sort of
state we're in are we in a good case or
a bad case
and so quickly we can look at
sort of what what sort of structures we
get out of this
so one thing that's sort of interesting
is we get something that's relatively
interpretable out so here these are our
point clouds here and so we're just sort
of looking at what's in our latent space
so we're trying to sort of see what
sorts of scenarios we can capture
through this encoder decoder
type approach
so if we look at this first latent
variable here
so one thing we can see here is we can
kind of see this swing from
right to left so this gives us some idea
of the orientation of the robot and
again in sort of a vague big sense um
here so this can kind of give us some
idea of whether or not we're sort of
centered or how we're adjusting to uh to
the robot here
if we look at this um other latent
variable here we can see this basically
says how close uh sort of these points
are so do we have something that is very
sort of close to us is there something
that's in front of us versus very open
sort of
free space that's in front of us so we
get something that's sort of
interpretable out
and again we can actually get very good
results in trying to identify these
these different scenarios
okay but numbers are a little bit boring
so let's look at some videos um here so
here's an example of
this online detection we have our lidar
data input here and we have our
probability of the different types of
scenes um scenes from here so you can
see we're pretty pretty good at saying
okay whether or not we're in normal uh
normal operation and when we sort of
switch over to
um things like road collisions and
whatnot here
so in this case we sort of hit an
obstacle but we were able to get over it
and it detected this as as traversable
okay but these are still all things that
sort of are similar to the video i
showed before let's look at some real
anomalies so in this case this is when a
wild grad student appears
who walks in front
and we're still able to detect
that
this grad student is not traversable so
we can detect things like that
we can also look at things
like trying to actively recover so
actually incorporating this into the
control paradigm so we can uh say run
into something like a roll collision we
can try to do something like a recovery
maneuver so we can try and back up the
robot so it can basically try again try
to see if it can proceed forward here
and basically what it's going to
identify after basically running into a
plant a bunch of times is that this is
probably not a row collision it's
probably just very stuck
so uh we can see it will try one more
time
here i have a better idea of basically
what is actually going on and then it
can do something like call for help from
from our human
okay and since i'm running a little bit
low
on time
i'll just say a few more things
so one thing that we don't actually like
about this system is yes we can now
detect failures but it's after it
happens so in this video this is
actually what's happening to the robot
this is not something we ever want to be
in
so just knowing that i'm in this state
is not actually that useful or that
informative so often what we want to do
is actually move towards proactive
detection
here
so what we have been trying to do is
basically push this to we actually can
incorporate this into the planning
process so we're going to have an idea
of sort of the risk over our planning
horizon so we can basically see based on
where we think we're going to go whether
or not we're in this sort of good zone
and if we're going to get into a
collision in the future so you can sort
of be a little bit more proactive about
stopping stopping these failures
and whatnot here
okay
and since i've been talking
quite a bit i will stop showing some
videos um here
and just note um a few things about this
um here so for these sorts of systems
where again you don't necessarily have a
good model of everything that's going on
um you can use things like anomaly
detection as a proxy for this failure
identification
and again we talked about some methods
that can basically help you identify
this by looking at this data
imbalance problem a little bit more
directly
and again we can extend this to a
predictive um approach um as well
but then one of the big questions is now
what so um since this is an online
approach it's not as obvious what you're
supposed to do with these failures when
we're looking at the autonomous vehicle
approach you want to fix it you want to
sort of uh as the engineer try to design
it better um this you're already out in
the field you sort of have it there um
one of the things you can actually do
though is start thinking about how to
actually connect it to the autonomy
itself so we can look at this sort of
failure identification as a way to sort
of give the robot more awareness so it
can do things like call for help so
we've explicitly looked at basically how
you can take these signals and these
sort of online estimates of what's going
on and try to do things like inform
inform the human what's going on
so um again that's uh basically all i
have we talked about these two different
scenarios where we have lots of
some structure not lots of structure
some structure in our environment and
very little and some different ways we
can actually look at how to identify
failures again to hopefully give us more
insight as designers or just give the
robot a little bit more insight to how
it's how it's doing
so i'd like to thank
all my collaborators who did most of the
work
on all this
and thanks for listening
so i'll take questions there's time
[Applause]
uh
go ahead
along with vision is sound a reliable uh
signal for
learning
especially for daughters
that's a great great question so i think
the
the sound
um it can actually i'm not entirely sure
for the autonomous driving case
um it's actually it's very useful for
robots like this though like the smaller
robots
um you can actually do things like
listen to the wheel encoders and get a
lot of information about what's what's
going on there so there's actually a lot
of insight you can get by like listening
more directly to to the robot so there's
some folks that look at that like for
mobile robotics
i'm not sure about uh vehicles i think
there's a lot of noise pollution
depending on where you are but
probably is also useful
yeah
yes does it know whether to uh go back
and try to kind of
go forward like one more time like it
was it seemed to repeat it
yeah that's a great question so we can
go back to that video and i'll talk uh
i'll talk over it a little bit more
um
so
oops
go back
can i get my video to show
okay so in this case um so we have these
different like classes uh here
so if we are in the case where we have a
row collision we can actually sort of
prescribe what we need to do so if we
know we are
one way or another so say we know we've
gotten to a collision say to the right
we know
with a
high likelihood if you back up and then
sort of go forward again uh that will
probably get you out of it um so as long
as this is the most likely
mode that we think we're in it'll
basically keep doing that
so it's basically a a prescribed set of
actions based on what you think you're
doing so if you're in normal operation
it would just try to go forward if it
thinks it's in a row collision it's
going to try to do this sort of recovery
recovery maneuver um similarly if it
were to say think it was in the
traversable mode which is now gone so
it's just something like a small
obstacle in front of it or something
like a weed
it would just try to go faster
which is also not a great solution
sometimes if you're wrong that's quite
bad actually
um but yeah so it's basically just a
simple logic based on where we think we
are
yeah
yes
i think you said that you're
comparing the reconstructed image with
the original image right yes uh how does
that comparison work do you do that in
the like for example for the images in
the pixel space or in the latent space
good question so uh you do it in the
pixel space or um depending on what
you're doing you can do it in like the
lidar point cloud space and whatnot and
the
there's two things that are tricky about
that one
there are tons of different metrics that
you can use
so you can use uh things like a pixel
wise or point wise error
which can cause issues but is relatively
straightforward or you can do things
like image similarity and whatnot um so
just choosing that uh
just becomes sort of a try a bunch and
see what works best and the other thing
that's hard about if you were to just
look at that reconstruction
error you have to pick a threshold at
some point um and in general
picking thresholds is always hard and
it's going to give you some some errors
um there so part of um that reason
is why we actually look at like this
this branch here so instead of us
explicitly saying okay like if the error
is more than 0.1 it's it's an alarm an
anomaly
we go through this classifier which is
basically coming up with that heuristic
for us
so it's basically uh learning itself
what the different modes are based on
on what we're extracting so
uh i guess the short answer is depending
depends on which perch you want to do
thank you
all right people have to wrap up there
but let's thank our speaker again
[Applause]